the same guys that you don't have for
years i mean obviously i'm such a big
you know gun guy right so the same guys
that for years told me
why do you need an ar-15 there's no
background check
it's ridiculous you know don what ar15
should i buy um
john oh my god there's a waiting period
what's going on i want a gun there's
stuff going on in my neighborhood i mean
i go
for 10 years you told me that these
things didn't exist because you had no
idea but that was the talking point
you know i think they're waking up to
how ridiculous it's become
do you miss the the good liberals
because uh we talked about this last
time but you're a new yorker
you grew up mostly around liberals
uh i know you have a lot of friends that
are still liberals
like do you miss that that new york
liberal that was not sort of the
banana's lefty
i i do and it's sort of interesting i
mean some of them are still that way and
honestly some of them are just like i
can't believe what's going on i'm like
you know the same guys that you know
have for years i mean obviously i'm such
a big you know gun guy right so the same
guys that for years told me
why do you need an ar-15 there's no
background check
it's ridiculous you know don what ar-15
should i buy um
john oh my god there's a waiting period
what's going on i want a gun there's
stuff going on in my neighborhood i mean
i go
for 10 years you told me that these
things didn't exist because you had no
idea but that was the talking point
you know i think they're waking up to
how ridiculous it's become so
you know it's been a little bit
cathartic for me because you know those
radicals that you know just you
literally
you know i used to be able to put myself
in their shoes argue their point it's
not like i
stick to 100 conservative dogma you know
that in the conversations we've had
way before we even got into politics i'm
pretty open about that and yet
you know i used to be able to argue
those points i can't argue the
mainstream democrat platform anymore
with a straight face and be like this is
this is somehow good for america
most of them can't and and that's the
problem they see it so
there's plenty of you know those
democrats i know a bunch that are just
like
yeah you know we don't love every aspect
of what you're doing but like we believe
in economy we believe in freedom we
believe in freedom of speech we believe
it
and you're listing these things that you
know i said in my convention speech like
you know freedom of speech and thought
that used to be a liberal value
you know try wearing your tolerance used
to be a liberal value i mean they still
run around they're the party of
tolerance i'm saying
try wearing a maga hat in portland you
know try wearing a magazine in one of
these major cities now if you wore
a biden hat i haven't seen any of them
but if if someone
made one and one there's got to be one
somewhere
yeah wear it in the most you know i
don't want to call it maga country
that's a jesse smellette special but
like
uh you know in in the most conservative
no one's gonna they won't even say
anything to you they won't
they won't spit at you they won't throw
they won't beat you over the head with a
brick like you're seeing in these videos
you know they won't loot your store or
cancel your business or
you'll get petitions going to to ruin
your life on facebook they won't do that
but try doing it the other way so you
know the party of tolerance isn't so
tolerant and i think a lot of reasonable
democrats
you know uh get that i also think a lot
of sort of that that history that
blue-collar working-class union democrat
that had a tradition of voting that way
i think they get it too
they're saying what is you know i used
to hear it in 16 well you know dawn if
my grandfather knew that i was voting
for a republican he'd be rolling over in
his grave
i go well what would he say about
today's democrat platform not that one
and he goes huh you know you're right
don like oh my god
i go how many genders are there 96 or
two what would he say
you know john f kennedy you know this
pillar of the democrat party he'd be all
right today dave he'd be cancelled
right he'd be meteored and canceled and
it would be over i mean
uh it's just not your grandfather's
democrat party anymore and i think
that has ostracized you know so many
former democrats where
they're starting to become you know
either somewhat conservative
uh moderate or or really you know sort
of libertarian in many of their views
which are so many of my views too
yeah i i hear you man and we've had many
discussions about it let's let's jump to
a private discussion we had about it
because i think it'll
it'll get to something really
interesting here which is uh
my audience has heard it but one night
uh you you and kimberly invited david
and i
to dinner at mar-a-lago we had a really
nice dinner we we argued about politics
for
two three hours uh i had a couple drinks
you do not drink so i'm not sure who won
the arguments
but we did about three hours there and
then at the end your dad was there and
by the way this was right at the
beginning of impeachment and everybody
said the walls are closing in he's
freaking out
the guy's sitting there he has no tie on
he was with giuliani and some people and
he's laughing and having fun
anyway at the end of dinner you said hey
would you like to meet my dad and i was
like uh yeah i'd like to
meet the president let's do it and you
introduce us and then
he turns to david and he says well who
are you and david says well
i'm his husband and your dad immediately
like there was no pause he
tapped his hands together he slapped him
on the table he said that's great that's
just great
i want to stand up and shake your hands
he shakes our hands he says the only
thing wrong with you guys is you're too
handsome melania can you believe it
these handsome guys are married and it
was just so
obvious to me that in this completely
unscripted
unplanned moment where you just brought
us
up to him that he he actually said i
don't know if he wants me saying it but
i've said it before
he said i want you guys to know
something i don't give a [ __ ]
and i don't think anyone's giving a [ __ ]
in in 20 years
talking about about gay marriage or
whatever um
how do you get over the labels when it
comes to something like that just
the base stuff your dad is or your
family is
homophobic or they're racist because no
matter how many times i tell that story
people say i'm a sellout somehow or
something you know some version of some
of that stuff
now well the reality is this donald
trump is the first
person to run for president of the
united states
that when he ran he was for gay marriage
i mean obama was against it because he
was told he had to be against it and
maybe he wasn't in his actual
convictions but as part of his platform
he was against it
because that's what they had to do right
that you listen to the talking points
and you must succumb to them
so you know again donald trump's been
way ahead of that curve i think we have
we're from new york i mean it's like a
pretty big percentage of the people
around us at any given time are probably
we just don't care what you do in your
own you know who gives a [ __ ] no one
no one's gonna care it's one of those
issues you're right i mean we're already
there frankly but in 20 years it'll be
even
even different or even even more so i
mean even some of the older school
people that you know
maybe a little bit more you know just
kind of read the
sort of the older religious dogma on it
like no one cares even the people that
say they care no they don't care they
sort of they feel obligated to do it
donald trump just had the guts to be
like hey i don't care i'm running for
the republican you know nomination and
this is not an issue for me whatsoever
go
have at it i always joke you know the
best wedding i ever went to was a gay
wedding because it was on a tuesday
they were like well we don't want to
screw up your weekend we're just going
to have fun on a tuesday that's
perfect this is the greatest wedding
ever i don't have to lose my whole
weekend that's awesome i love you guys
um and so you know he hasn't came but
again you see it every day
donald trump has been so pr i think you
guys didn't have a problem with obama
literally running against gay marriage
in 2008 but donald trump runs
as a conservative literally going
against
the you know the more traditional dog
might again i don't think it's a party
platform issue at this point
like i said i don't think anyone cares
they probably haven't for a while but he
literally said i don't care
well you know guess what you know you're
a republican you're trying to get the
evangelical vote and you still say hey i
don't care about that
let people live and let live i mean the
republican party is the true party of
tolerance
now that doesn't mean you know you know
i've been open about this too and it
doesn't mean i don't draw the line some
places again
i don't care how you even identify where
i start to care is when
you know you're 6'2 285 and jack and you
decide you want to be a woman and
compete against you know my daughter in
sports
you know i i don't identify how you want
but you start taking her scholarship
i have a problem i wonder where the
people who fought for title ix are
how come they won't say anything but
it's interesting when i've come out on
some of those things and again i don't
give a crap if you're trans or not that
makes no difference to me it's when
you sort of let's let's have the best
let's take a female athlete who's
top of her game who's worked her whole
life i'm a journeyman male athlete it's
not working out so well congratulations
i'm going to flip and now i'm a state
champion i'm getting your scholarship
i have a problem with that and i've said
it i've been very vocal about it i've
even put it out on twitter
and it's interesting because if i put
out anything on twitter you know
before someone could have even read you
know read my tweet
they're up there with the hate mail and
the hate commentary but when i do that
one
it's sort of interesting i get this note
like damn it
ah man god damn it i hate him but i'm
with don jr on this one
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell